all right Shelly
Shelly uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally
Manchester Kentucky
tell me about your family growing up uh
I was writing foster care
you know what happened to your mom and
dad oh yeah I got strung out I guess
alcoholic
did you get adopted by another family I
was raised by another family yeah how
was your childhood with them
uh after I got my fosterone it's lovely
how would you describe your childhood in
general
um I come from a broken home
you said the family that eventually
adopted you was good
how far are you in school no
why'd you quit school
fun
you started getting in trouble with the
law early yeah my my youngest I didn't
give a [__] yeah
they took your youngest child I took
them all
how many kids do you have I gave birth
to six
where are the kids now they're scattered
look great how good homes
you've been in and out of jail prison
so how many years have you been
uh since I've been not nine year again
the drugs have been a part of your life
too
maybe that start I'm gonna cut my kids
about 19.
they start about 19. not a cone crank
Baby Daddy come to jail and then
um
I thought I was having him got a lawyer
started dating him and then my baby
daddy got sent to prison and then before
he knew it my baby was gone
my youngest
yes
six a total of six how many different
fathers
two two
and the dads are not in the picture
either
that's dead
except for his oldest my oldest dad
he's alive
so tell me about staying here in jail in
Kentucky your typical day looks like
what what do you do
Miss Hound me this is home to you
your friends here
all over
well I don't know about friends but
family
what are your typical day you wake up
and you do what
historic space
is it easier for you here than out in
the street
why is that what is it about oh no
worries here
no bills no nothing
you've been in love before
oh yeah
how'd that work out he's dead
he made bad poor decisions I guess you
know I mean he's a good daddy but
he died I guess we got hit by a car I
wasn't there
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently
I stay away from drugs man real men
are men the problem or drugs drugs
I think drugs is the way I bonded with
men you know what I'm saying like I was
lonely so I'd done drugs
and then the drugs bonded us that's what
we've done for fun
just being an appellation part of the
problem because there's not a whole lot
to do here and then weekend comes around
yeah
yeah it seems like that's why so many
people are involved in them
you get caught up yeah I'm a mom when I
took my Nest away I didn't have nothing
to lose
yeah brothers and sisters yeah
a lot
are they similar to you or are you
walking a different path than they are I
walk a different path
they're doing something a little
straighter a little more conventional
why do you think your Life Path is so
different from theirs because I'm
Different what is it that makes you
different I don't I go by spirit I don't
go by what society says I do what my gut
says you like the black sheep well do
you know 39 what's your biggest fear
nine getting old how many years are you
gonna be in here I'm done here when do
you get out I don't know if I go to a
different County
I don't care I'm ready to get my mind
together however long it takes
time's time you're not really looking
forward to getting out if you say this
is home
what was your favorite memory in your
life my first born child
everything kind of went South after that
after you lost it first you lost him
because of drugs yeah I don't talk about
that
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your life not
her family for granted
did you ever meet your biological
parents yeah I love them one's dead and
one's
trying to make up
you got people visiting here
visiting you here in in uh
I don't want to talk about that my
baby's here for me no more regardless
what emotions do you deal with most
of my kids so is that depression anger
anxiety
what's your biggest regret
my biggest regret
I'd have to say not Casey law my husband
I'm sorry okay not Casey law my husband
got killed
all right John thank you so much for
sharing your story you're welcome I wish
you the best of luck out here thank you